hi when Cindy is and the director of the
department at McCarran California were
commentarydota2 but when I look at what
I think are the most important things
that people can come together around it
would be recognizing the inherent
dignity and worth of each individual of
all the things that I think ultimately
we were getting way of solving problems
it is the fact that we are able to
dehumanize over Tampa and to put them in
a position where they're sorry for your
concerns and their suffering really
don't impact us because in anyways it
gets too hard to care but that in that
resistance or distance from caring
really leads us in many ways to keep you
nice people oh and inherently strip them
of self-portrait so of all the things
that I would hope to see
happened in 2008 it was a global health
of inertia that every mother cares about
her children as much as I do as much as
we do that every lot of tiger who cares
deeply about the ability to put their
family and that these things don't
differ and that you must be helping
people to from their dignity and
humanity